guy lagache et ben on le retrouve alors
bien sûr on le retrouve tous les
mercredis sur des beats et obtient
d'ailleurs guy dis moi ce que j'aime
ville est toujours beau gosse regardez
franchement quand il présente enquête
d'actualité le mercredi gardez la line
up parking tout coup de lagaf' regardez
regardez commune et vous regardez
ghardaïa pas une autre photo mais j'ai
trouvé que cette photo des saboteurs ça
veut dire le mais clairement il est
toujours beau basse et ont trouvé la
seule photo le gars on dirait qu'il
vient de s'embrouiller avec un mec en
voiture comme et sans rigoler c'est mais
elle est pire c'est pas trop non plus
voilà voilà non vous avez vu ce que je
vais tous les jours y ait un toit ya des
gardiens via des grillons je crois bien
que oui alors à télé manger avec moi guy
abbas si je perds moi si je perds je
n'en suis qu'à se mange pas c'est ce que
disait toujours à ma femme
attention on y va à fond mais attention
alors sous disquette dans je vous dise
quête d'eau il ya des criquets des
grillons des blagues des larves des
verts et des chamallows voilà donc il
faudrait tomber sur les chabal ou quoi
on a une chance sur six est pour vous
montrer que je ne triche pas vous
choisirez ma boîte si je perds mon dit
lagache à 2,3 chez face à hewitt et la
feuille
la folle englobe la pierre et toof la
pierre la terre manquent d'oxygène
la paire d'heures à saint-pierre moeurs
choisissez une boîte
allez-y faites vous plaisir qui dit moi
non pas vous si tu me regardes alors 1 2
3 4 5 6 l'a3 l'a3 à la veille de la 3e
rencontre
je vais découvrir sur sugar attention je
vais regarder ce qu'il ya de vrai les
chamallows sur l île à une est non il a
un cul suisse la brèche mais sa
maladresse et des chiens ballon c'est
non à la question c'est quoi ta chanson
préférée même chanson préférée oui ma
chanson préférée mais de toute la vie de
toute la vie un mouvement neuf de coeur
[Rires]
alors regardez le pays qui fait des
volumes avait chanté duquel j grâce à
jean loup velut toute nouvelle étude il
était trop esseulé mais patrick rose est
vrai et coutumes et étouffer jeune âge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non michael allen whatever il ne reste
que des trucs dégueulasses
alors attention un chiffrement joue mais
hélas est le fuseau coupe la pierre
à
ou apprendre la seule province au lieu
de dire on va prendre l'a5 aller là cinq
étudiants me battre on y va on y va
qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors alors
ça si on prend par la main
c'est quoi ça oui regardez venez là ah
ouais non mais c'est vivant peut pas les
meilleurs et des platanes ont alors est
ce qu'on va manger ça plus tard guy je
sais pas j'ai pas enquêté bâtiment
oui c'est plein de gouaille être à votre
place mais non encore la gravité mais
valérie me l'a dit vivant on peut pas un
nom alors je veux bien la prendre dans
la main du terrain petit bisou à la
voilà du parti qui joue à la bla bla
nuit une grosse non mais franchement pas
ce que vient la vache qui rit bien
lacées regarde c'est tout on regarde où
se ressentent grave et c'est que ça
saute 7 mai les grillons
on ne serait pas étonné de risque au
canada les houches et d'attention de les
écraser pas écraser par janot lady de
les écraser par des grilles on ne les
écrase et pas voilà merci regardez je
suis pas un petit bisou voilà voilà